[Music]
hallo YouTube chess Louis and my friends
this is guns in here welcome to the
thirty third episode of my chest trap in
this episode I'm going to show you one
of the beautiful and cunning trap in the
Quinns Indian defense from the black
perspective now the most surprising part
is one of the chest grades Sigma tirage
once fall into this trap and not only
him time to time every year many strong
players are falling into this trap so if
you know this trap from both the side
then it is going to be very helpful for
the tournament practice
the opening arises after the following
order d4 Knight to f6 and here it
doesn't matter whether white continue
with Knight to f3 or the MU c4 let's say
in this game the rash continue with
Knight to f3 and after the move a six
white indeed played the move C phone
which gives him the space on the Queen
side ok now comes the typical trade mark
Queen's Indian mu B 6 and we dish to the
starting point of this opening so as you
can see black wants to activate his life
square Bishop and accordingly White has
tried different responses well amongst
them Knight to c3 and g3 are most
frequently played more however in this
episode we are going to look at one of
the most popular choice by white camp
namely Bishop to g5
so idea is very simple white not only
pin down the snide but he wants to play
III so that way his Bishop remains
outside the pawn chain
okay no shoes black continue it Bishop
to b7 putting that Bishop on a lovely
long diagonal and accordingly white
liberate his light square bishop with
the moon III
now next two moves of the black are very
important as it sets up the basic
platform for the upcoming trap the first
one is very obvious at six asking the
Christian to the bishop and if why
decided to grab the knight then black is
more than happy as he's going to capture
with the Queen and the net result is
black obtain the bishop pair and in a
long run this will indeed cue advantage
to the black cab
so I don't think so any good white
player will do this and instead of that
what will indeed like to maintain this
pain with Bishop 24 which happens in the
90 percent of the games well so far both
the side has played the logical response
however now comes the move which sets up
a very beautiful trap and that is Bishop
to b4 check
white has to natural response to block
this check
however after night to D to white indeed
fall into of a beautiful trap
now before we look night 2d2 the
important point I like to mention here
that if you open and continue with
Knight to c3 then the followings forcing
sequence gives black a slight advantage
and a good attacking position the first
obvious movies g5
attacking the bishop and after Bishop to
g3 we are going to pressurize this c3
Knight with Knight to e4
so white responses force white has to
defend this night with Queen to c2 but
then after the movie fi not only black
gets space on the kingside but he has a
simple plan to execute namely d6 Knight
to d7 27 and then castle on the Queen
side which not only secured his king but
later on black and look forward for a
quick king side activity which is not
easy to dealt with as a white camp so
this is how you should response if you
open and continue with Knight to c3
okay it's a trapa time and let's check
out what is going on after the moon
night B to D - which is a very natural
response as Y doesn't want to create a
double pond on the C file in fact in the
database there are more than 60 games
goes into this direction where I feel
very sorry for the white game as it
directly fall into of a beautiful trap
now before I move on I like you to pause
this video and find out a sequence where
black instantly obtained of winning
advantage
you
are you ready let's get started
the phosphor is very obvious GFI
attacking the bishop bishop goes to the
only square g3 and after that I hope you
find this deciding moon g4 dislodging
this nine which is a defender of the d2
night and now it doesn't matter whether
white continued with Knight to e5 or e3
it all leads to completely losing
position for the white camp number one
if I try to move the knight let's say
Knight to e5 then the simplest response
is Knight to e4 and now you can see the
pitiable thing for this pin night he
needs support right but nobody is
helping him more or less at this point
White is a piece down and the best he
can do is grab a pawn but this is not
going to help as after Bishop captures
d2 came to Devin and the move Queen to
g5 black emerged with a clear piece up
and white has absolutely no compensation
for it
well in the game the rush realized at
this point that he is going to lose a
piece so he decided to counter-attack
the black Bishop with the moon a3 so his
idea is if now black captured on d2 then
white will recapture with his knight and
white is no longer in trouble but what
he missed out is after the MU G captures
f3 pawn captures before and the mu F
captures g2 akane white is losing a
piece in a broad daylight and even the
rush continue with few moves at the end
he has to resign in mere 28 mos
that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn this beautiful trap in the Queen's
Indian defense remember once you
opponent play the move Knight to d2 the
lost is written on his head on the spot
well thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
and I will meet you in my next episode
very soon bye and take care